- I'm gonna make you wait
and I'm gonna make you wait.
Because this is a lot
to handle all at once.
- Sex on the first date,
is that cool?
Like is it, is it cool?
It's debatable.
- I am for having sex on the first date.
- If the values obtaining a relationship,
I am against sex on the first date.
- I'm pro freedom and I'm
pro sex on the first date.
- I am against having
sex on the first date.
- If you're feeling it, I am
pro sex on the first date.
- No, no, no sex on the first date.
- I think first dates, in general,
are very performative, but if you
get to the point where like,
you feel comfortable enough
with that person to have sex with them,
you should go for it.
- Why build walls for yourself?
You're on a date, things are going well
and you engage in healthy, normal sex.
- Having sex on the first date,
it also just nips it right
in the bud, that whole are we gonna be
compatible in bed question.
- Somebody who wants to have
sex on the first date should
do it because they'll find
out that they're incompatible.
Like, I don't think sexual
tension just dissapates
after you have sex for the first time.
- I think it does.
I think if you are a heterosexual woman
and you are interested in a guy,
you should not have sex
with him on a first date.
- What makes me really sad about that,
is that it's operating
under the assumption,
like, don't give the boy what he wants
because the boy is terrible
and if he gets what he wants
he won't want you anymore.
- I don't think you should
go into a first date
thinking you're gonna hook
up with this person tonight.
I would say to be open to it.
- If you're feeling it with someone
and you're not going to have sex with them
on the first date just
because it's the first date,
you know, I feel like that's a limitation.
Life's too short.
That person could be hit
by a bus the next day.
- When you watch a movie
and you hear that there's
a really great scene
later on in the movie,
you don't skip all the setup
and the character development.
Who just jumps into the scene select,
goes to the cool scene, watches it
and then goes back to the beginning?
- Is it a sex scene?
'Cause I'll jump ahead.
- It's a first date, have a date.
Kiss a little bit.
Next time, you'll do the sex
part of the relationship.
- I like just building up
that like, excitement for it.
- You're looking for a relationship,
you're gonna be in a relationship,
so slow down.
- Once you like, grow a
relationship with someone,
the sex is better.
- Yeah, so it could just get
better and better and better.
All because you meaningless
sex with someone one day
doesn't mean it can't be
meaningful, even better the next.
- You can't get to know someone
sharing an entree at Olive Garden.
If you're making that
decision after two hours
then you're just telling
them, I just think you're hot.
Let's essentially masturbate together.
Great sex isn't just about
having a physical connection.
It's about intimacy and real knowledge
of the other person, of their personality.
- Just let it all go, just two animals.
Just letting those instincts overtake you.
- Some people can use their intellect
to overpower their human nature,
but you can't deny that
human nature exists.
- I think doing what feels right
is typically an okay thing.
Especially when it comes to first dates.
They're pretty performative.
- You're in control of
whether you do or not.
So, at the end of the day,
if you do have your power,
it doesn't make you easy.
- I don't think anybody
deserves me all in one night.
To be honest with you.
- Well, I 100 percent believe that.
You're someone who like,
no one could deserve you ever.
- These are called nudes.
- Can we take some of those home?
- Yeah, the guy who doesn't want
to have sex on the first
date needs condoms.